would you uh
ever try to infuse some of the caribbean
[ __ ] you came up listening to in your
household and do your music even yeah
surprise about track you can hear the
accent
on certain words but i'm gonna make a
whole wait i would say um
what you need what you need is the vibe
of it is a caribbean right
you know young blue on that oh
young blue ladies and gentlemen i was
just supposed to say that
it is what it is the young blue dude
west coast with it the empire avengers
they have united on a song
and it is coming soon and there's some
caribbean vibes on it ladies and
gentlemen
that's a crazy intro right there there
it is coming soon
i'm going to see i'm supposed to see
blue this week so i'm going to ask him
about it
i heard you yeah i got one you know
outside of
outside of blue who else i mean you know
who else do you want to work with that
you haven't worked with yet
um everybody like i said before i [ __ ]
with all my son
who scheisty [ __ ] little baby all of
them gonna
um what about it give me a new a new
york og if you could pick a new york og
any one of them to work with who would
it be
i don't know cuz i'll say it gotta be
jay-z guys
how old it gotta be